today i have a a game of mine planned
and it's gonna
keep going you know with the theme that
we have been doing
in understanding practical chess you
know since the beginning of the year
and that's going to be attacking you
know and fighting for the initiative and
being on the attack
eventually i think we're going to to
also study
things like defense that's probably the
next uh
topic that i'm going to be talking about
in the upcoming
um lectures but for now you know we're
focusing on
uh different types of attack and
today it's going to be more of like uh
following your intuition
and the whole goal is to um
maybe not you know see the moves as the
engine sees them
but kind of see them with like a human
point of view
and essentially my what i hope today is
that i can
help you or inspire you maybe to uh
trust more in your gut in your instinct
uh when you play games because you know
it's i feel like it's a difficult thing
and i can tell you about the backstory
of this game which i think you know kind
of
um could you know
help i always try to talk a little bit
about you know
uh psycho psychology and psychological
you know states of mind for playing
chess
and i kind of like to add them to the to
the actual solid concrete lesson
so i think the backstory of this game is
kind of
interesting and you know what
subsequently happened
um but this game was played in
[Music]
no november december december
of 2017
and it you know it happened
in a tournament called carlos story
i think many people you know are already
kind of familiar with that event
because it's probably one of if not the
most
famous tournament in
mexico and i personally really enjoy
going to it
every time that i can because as some of
you may know i am from cuba
and um it's a country where i can you
know speak spanish i have been there a
couple of times so i understand
and also like a bunch of my q and
friends come and play this tournament so
this is like
one time when i get to see them and uh
usually it's pretty great um so
this tournament just kind of brings me a
lot of joy in general and i do believe
that when you're
playing chess in an environment that is
you know pleasant
and can kind of enhance your chess
probably because you know it's it's not
a worry
like you don't have to worry about the
conditions you're in
you're just you just kind of have to um
enjoy i guess you it's all you have to
do so
um i do think i mean of course it's not
a thing you can control the environment
in which you play a chess tournament but
um it's always nice when it's
comfortable right so
i'm guessing that's my point um
but yeah so i think before
this event i was struggling a little bit
i think my rating had gone down
in the summer of 2017 i got to 21.99
uscf rating and that's a pretty big deal
because i'm very close to master
i'm 21.99 and then i lost some rating
i think i was at like 21.70 or something
and as you guys can see from the screen
i'm 2053
fide so um still
uh much lower than what my rating is
nowadays um
but um i kind of um
was hoping that things would turn around
in this tournament
and they kind of did right off the bat
and i wasn't really expecting it
but you know this tournament just kind
of i think turn around
my following events you know if that
means anything so um
yeah so this is round one as you guys
can see i'm playing
a 2400 i believe he's a he's an i am
and i also know this guy from you know
my years as a player in cuba i think he
may have like been to my house once
because i have
plenty of story i used to live in the
same apartment building
as a as probably the arbiter of most of
the
chess tournaments in havana and also
like a
an instructor so usually i would go to
tournaments with him
uh if my mom couldn't go with me and
this guy this i am who i am playing
right now he's from another province but
when he played tournaments
in um havana he would stay at
the arbiter's house so it was just um
i guess you know i just kind of knew him
around
um yeah
so we can start with the with the game
so it started with knight to f3
knight to f3 knight to f6
g3 g6 b3 and
this lines are usually kind of difficult
to understand
um because you know you kind of it's
very vague
so you don't really know like what's
your opponent's idea
or anything and um
it's generally like difficult to
to actually know like what's their plan
but if you ever get into a situation
where like your opponent is being a
little bit vague about the move order
um just try you know to always look out
for
for moves that can take you away from
the structures or the opening that you
know
for example i play the groomfield so
um i'm going to make sure that my
opponent can never do something like
e4 because i'm just kind of that just
kind of
changes um
the opening or the you know it just kind
of takes me out of
out of my comfort zone and that's not
really what i want
so um i'm just going to make
you know typical gumfeld moves
and
you know if he tries to do something
like for example if he plays like knight
c3 here
i know that he wants to play for next
move so i'm not going to castle i'm
gonna play d5
does that make sense so
um yeah
but after after
bishop to g7
bishop to b2
was played and bishop to b2
d5 i wasn't exactly sure of
what i was doing but i mean it kind of
feels like it should be
kind of feels like it should be fine um
wait that line just went back for some
reason
but yeah i was mentioning that knight c3
d5
but uh up after bishop to
b2 d5 you know i'm just gonna
get into the structure that that i know
this is very groomful
ask and as usual i didn't know what i
was doing i'm not an opening expert
not even to this day but as long as you
you know try to meant to stay in the
in the variations that you know the
plans
uh you should be all right just develop
your pieces keep your kings safe don't
get into too
too much trouble and you should probably
be fine
don't make like extremely committing
moves in positions that you don't know
it feels like that's
uh like a recipe for disaster it may
work sometimes
i'm not telling you that it doesn't
fully work
but it's kind of a difficult thing so
but bishop to g2 castle
c4c6 and
um yeah so i think once i may have
reviewed
a variation with c5 but this is not
really what i was um
thinking about playing i kind of wanted
to keep my opponent c6
um but for example this is fine and
after it takes takes bishop takes skin
takes castle
knight c6 d4 and this is you know
an end game it's it's normal it's fine
but i wanted to play with c6 because i
have some ideas of playing with knight
d7 rook e8
and e5 if he doesn't play with e4 and if
he does play with e4 then maybe i can
put my knight on e4
and you know do like a similar idea but
with the knight on e4
so i just wanted to play more solidly
and after castle knight d7
d3 was playing and i was kind of
pleased to be honest uh when i saw this
move because it doesn't feel like it's
super ambitious
i don't know about you but i personally
think that
it's just kind of a move um
d5 just seems to be more ambitious and
with d3 i didn't really like fully
understand the purpose
um if d4 for example i was going to
continue with the plan that i had
mentioned knight to e4
and if knight c3 takes takes and i can
bring my other knight over
to a4 and the position is solid
but with um d3 it felt like i could
maybe expand in the center and if you
know me you know that i like
having space and control in the center
that's my preferred type of position
so i'm not opposed to this of course
root 28 my idea is to go a5 you know
supporting the
the pawn and after it takes
takes knight to c3 i think
i am not entirely sure because you know
it has been a lot of time
but i think that we may have spent like
between
five to ten minutes on this like
moves that are happening now kind of in
the middle of um
like in the middle of opening a middle
game trying to figure out where our
opponent's structure is going to be
like we were spending quite a bit of
time because the position seems to be
like very
vague or like very fluid if that makes
sense like there's a lot of
possibilities here
so um like we're just
kind of at least i personally i was
looking
into like the different pawn structures
that we could uh
ever get in the position and making sure
that
you know none of them were possibly bad
for me or uncomfortable for me like i
was just making sure that
if you know at any point like there's a
chance to get a pawn structure
that i don't like it wouldn't happen so
yeah
um but e5 i'm very pleased with the
position so far
uh rook 2 c1 and
here i played a6 i don't know to me just
kind of felt natural because i don't
want the knight
coming to like b5 and controlling the
squares
so when bishop is on the other diagonal
um and if he had done it and moved
before
it's not as good like here knight b5 is
not as good because i have queen b6
in the other line you know like they
would have a rook on c1 so it doesn't
matter they could still go knight c7
but here they don't so
but yeah rook c1a6 um i had
uh i had thought about this but i didn't
actually play it
but knight b8 is a funny idea uh because
for example if knight b5 you can go
knight c6
and the knight is so much better in c6
than it is on
on the d7 i'm sorry to say because it is
my knight but
the knight on c6 is just so much better
because
it control it helps e5 um it blocks the
file for the rook uh it helps you know
the queen controls c7 and
d6 primarily d6 you know now that there
is no knight on d7
and it opens up the way for the bishop
and
it's just you know overall much better
place
so this knight b8 idea would have been
very interesting too
um i feel like it's very known like in
the
what is the name in the in the spanish
in the relopus like there's this carlson
idea where the knight on c6 goes to
b8 and d7 and for some reason this
maneuver of knight
b8 and knight c6 kind of reminds me of
him
but yeah so i played a6 in the game
and now my opponents went e4
i believe i had thought about this move
but i thought it was very committal
like i thought that i didn't think my
opponent would play it because i thought
it was very committal
but i don't think he knew how to play
dispositions either it felt like we were
both just kind of lost in the desert
because you know we were both like
spending time already
and neither of us like was you know
super confident about our moves we're
just kind of
uh thinking and playing and
what i think about e4 is that
i don't know it just kind of feels like
it's going to give me
quick initiative um other options would
have been something like
uh knight to d2 for example and
you know to attack here and if knight b6
something like h3
no bishop here or anything and just be
solid there
but after e4 i think d4 makes a lot of
sense
d4 and knight to e7
and now the position is very interesting
it's very interesting because it feels
like black can play on both sides of the
board
which is not you know usual and it feels
like i have
equalized and maybe something slightly
more
um i remember i was looking into this
position
and you guys can take a moment to to
evaluate this with me
um i'm gonna just mainly talk about you
know the main aspects of the position
that i can see right now
but usually if you don't know a position
or have never seen it before or simply
don't understand what's going on
there are a couple of things you can you
know look at
to make sure that you understand better
and the things that you can look at are
uh material king's safety like
you know how save the castle king or
just the key in general is
uh placement of the pieces and palm
structure
so you can do an analysis of those see
who's better on each aspect
and in the order that i mentioned them
uh it's also the order
of importance you know
you can consider based on that like a
bit more about the position
and if you feel like your opponent has a
weak king
then maybe you know you should be
thinking about attacking it
you know uh if you have better peace
placement
try to slowly squeeze your opponent um
ideas like that so uh whether you have a
permanent
or relative pawn structure advantage i
don't know
stuff like that but here it feels like i
have the space which is really nice
i have the space uh my development is
fine my king is fine the only thing is
that
it would probably be nice if i could you
know get my knight out of the way so
that i can move my bishop
but i would say that in this position
the biggest thing that black has
is pawn structuring which pawns on e5
and d4
control most of the center and the
position just seems
like it's going to be comfortable to
play for black because there are no
clear weaknesses either
so yeah and
um in the game i played the move knight
to f8
and i feel like this is very natural as
i was saying um
i want to develop my bishop on c8 and it
makes a lot of sense for me to
try and do that now um however
in this position this is another
interesting move
which is a5 a5 is very interesting
because it can go
you know with the idea of a4 and i feel
like this is very natural you guys have
probably seen it
um you know in in positions where you
know there's opponent b3
uh maybe to go a5 a4 control some space
on the queen side maybe somehow
open up the file for the rook so they
can become active
but it was just a nice idea of the
position b5 ah
sorry a4 looks like it's going to be
very weakening
of the opponent b3 so i wouldn't
recommend it
but i went knight to f8 and knight to e8
was played
um yeah
and i was very surprised when i saw this
uh because you know when you look at 98
you ask yourself
okay what is my opponent's idea oh my
dog is barking i don't know if you guys
can hear it
but um it's a common thing with my
streams
so my opponent's idea is to go
f4 right or at least that's what i
thought they wanted to go
f4 uh because
dog is sparking that they wanted to go
f4 because you know they kind of want to
fight for some sort of
um initiative you know counterplay
something feels like you know if they
don't do a plan like this
and make it simply outplayed
if that makes sense so yeah at first i
thought it was a weakening plan because
you know f4 is a very committal move
and i guess also it has to do with the
fact that this bishop is not on the main
diagonal
at least i would call this well
essentially this would be the main
diagonal but in this position it kind of
looks like
it's meaningless because white can't
really do anything in this diagonal
but um f4 i just felt like it was going
to weaken this a lot especially if my
bishop comes to h6
um and
yeah at first i wasn't so convinced
about it but then i thought okay if
white doesn't do this plan what else
could they do and then i couldn't find
another
you know concrete answer to that so
take a moment in this position i'm gonna
make a tiny little pause
and i'm going to ask you so 91
let's say that this is your game you
know that your opponent wants to play
f4 right and that's the one
potential liberation that they have in
the position
how can you continue as black knowing
that
and uh you guys can think for a couple
of seconds i feel like i got mater right
now
being like okay think for a moment now
congratulations
uh what what does he say
wait i think it's like congratulations
he said
like for those of you who want to
um for those of you who found the move
congratulations
no he says no okay whatever anyways so
the best move right here is g5
which is very interesting and it kind of
gives me some vibes of the
bononi like you guys know how in the
benoni sometimes you know you play g5 to
control
f4 kind of give me some vibes of that
and um the idea is that now if
f4 after it takes takes knight g4 with
the ideas of
getting the knight to e3 knight c2
takes takes knight g6 the knight that
was on f8 is now
coming to life and i would say that the
position is very solid for
for black you know d4 is well covered
feels like the dark squares around the
king are going to be weak like the queen
can come to g5 or h4
and it feels like black i'm being a bit
of trouble after that
um in general the black pieces seem to
be a bit more
active and coordinated
than white's pieces so
g5 is a very nice very interesting idea
definitely
another move was maybe bishop g4
also looks rather nice uh
because if f4 right away it just looks
very dangerous
uh it could be maybe a possibility but
i don't know it feels like for example
if takes takes
there could maybe be ideas now of knight
to d5
i don't know knight to d5 because of
course if takes bishop takes e2
and uh there are you know two pieces on
our attack knows
and then out on d5 threatens knight to
e3 so i feel like there can be some
tricks
but unfortunately after bishop g4
there's a can be
h3 and when the bishop comes back then
f4 and i believe this is one of the
variations i was considering during my
game
but i couldn't really figure out what to
do against h3 i don't want to give up my
bishop guy
um so in the game i played with bishop
to h6 kind of has a similar idea as g5
but it's not as effective
and i feel like if i play bishop h6 you
know i'm kind of attacking this rook
my opponent has no option but to play
four and this is what happened in the
game
and after f4 takes he took with the
knight
he took with the knight i think if he
had taken with the pawn
i would probably have continued what
would i have continued with
i was going to say knight to g4 but i'm
not sure if that's
exactly what i was thinking about
i guess i could continue with something
like knight 2 e6
and it seems to be rather solid then i
could
have some ideas of maybe knight to g4
but the position looks fine in my
opinion for
for black
my opponent however took with a knight
and i went knight to e6 and he went rook
to c4 i believe this
is a move that i actually had missed um
yeah and there's a very interesting line
here
so i did not play this in the game i
went to knight takes f4
but there is a very interesting line
here you guys can take a another moment
to see if you want to find it you can
probably pause the video i'm guessing
this is one of those videos that you can
pause
or like youtube i don't know where this
is going but
um you can pause it or you can just
solve it while i'm talking i don't
really mind
but um so
another nice idea was b5 and i didn't
consider this probably as much as i
should have and after it takes takes
rook to c6 you
wouldn't take uh because now
there is bishop to e3 and there's this
you know
double threats
and for example after it takes rook c6
bishop b3
queen d7 and once again the black
position just seems to be a lot more
coordinated
and nice right so b5 directly was
a good try since their intermediate move
doesn't really work
um however i just play knight takes f4
which is also fine
and after it takes i made this very
interesting move
now i can give you i can give you once
again time to think
and i feel like this is kind of a
crucial moment
i feel like this is kind of a crucial
moment because there are
you know uh different
possibilities uh for
for black
and the question is just how to how to
proceed
it would have been probably nicer if i
had played b5 because it means that i
would get a position very similar to
this one
just you know that the pawn is on g3 and
that allows for ideas of bishop e3
so that's probably the main thing of why
knight takes f4 is not as good
but still the black position is fine um
you just kind of have to come up with an
idea now
and i remember that during the game of
course
i don't have an engine or anything so i
was just thinking with my
tiny little brain and
i was trying to to find the line that i
wanted and by the line that i wanted him
it means that
i was looking at this position i kind of
knew that there was
you know potential for stuff but i
didn't know exactly how
um
i didn't know exactly how i just kind of
knew that there were going to be you
know some
practical ideas coming up and
the the nice move here would probably be
knight to h5
knight to h5 attacking the pawn
uh if bishop to c1 for example now b5
and bishop back to g7 now that it's not
really putting a lot of pressure here
um but in the game i went knight to g4
and i think that this decision is very
practical
and you know we have about
i would say 25 minutes in this position
i know it's very early it's move 18. but
we have about 25 minutes i want to
assume
and the position is about to get
complicated
and you know i have chances to
complicate things
and i thought why not to go for it and
um
uh i think you know
the engine comes to you whatever it
wants about this position but just look
at it
and you know just try to understand
what's going on because i feel like it's
not
it's not simple and it's not clear to
see
how white is so much better
um so there are you know some main
things that we can notice
of course the bishop takes d4 you can
also once again take a moment to stop
here since there is a tactic
and if you did find it um
congratulations you're an excellent
pawn mover let's call it pawn mover yeah
v5
and the rook is going to get stuck
trying to defend this bishop and it
literally counts
though uh this bishop is going to hang
with check and it's going to be a lot of
trouble
so taking with the bishop is not
possible and as the game went rogue
takes d4
going to b6 making a pin so now we have
this
and ideas of this and probably sorry
and probably this so
it's not clear to know what's happening
and during the game
i didn't really know what was happening
but i could
feel like this was fine if that makes
sense like
i could i could feel like this was
interesting enough for me to go for it
and this is one big thing i think it's
really nice
and really helpful that for some reason
that i can't really explain
i had the courage to go for a variation
like this and i'm gonna explain
why that may sound like i mean of course
that may sound
kind of um stupid because you should
always have
the confidence to go for good variations
but you know i'm also playing an
international master
i am very young and also probably my
mental state was uh
a lot less um
how should i say it was like uh
now i am more confident in my abilities
okay
so i should probably i would probably go
for you know attacking lines against
grandmasters and such but at the time i
kind of wasn't so sure
and uh i always kind of doubted my
variations
and i think something happened in this
tournament that helped me realize that i
probably shouldn't do that because
um it you know i shouldn't adopt in my
calculation because i calculate just
fine and also
it makes me waste a big amount of time
so um
i was kind of just more confident all
around uh
confident all around in my moves
and this kind of went on to my next
tournament and i'm gonna probably find
a game from that tournament to show and
you know it kind of went on to my next
image which was in
vegas and
i i wasn't i don't think i was even like
the top 10 seat
maybe top 15 i don't know but i was a
2175 i think uscf
playing in the north american
open in vegas under 2300 section
and by the end of it i got to
in that tournament by the end of it i
got to
uh second place which is nice i got some
prize money for that
and also i crossed 2200 by a big margin
so i was like 20 170 something and then
i jumped to 22
30 something like 35 or something and
this is because i had one really great
tournament
didn't lose any games um
but you know if you are
this is why i was saying if you're like
around the master level
um and you have you know like a rating
relatively close to your goal
i would recommend you to just you know
act as if nothing is happening
play a tournament and you know play with
your love of chess right then
scheduling a game to play
win and um crossing that barrier
i think that you can't really force
things to happen
and that you should i don't know um
just continue playing as if it's nothing
because i had a bad experience
with um arranging a game and all of that
but
um i was having it's funny because i was
having trouble like with
crossing 2200 and then i
don't worry about it and in the
tournament that i don't worry about it i
not only jump it but like eat it almost
22 like from 21 70 something to 22 30
that's a bunch of points
so um yeah
but anyways going back to this game i
just started diving and talking about
psychology
um but going back to this game we have a
lot to unpack
so as you can probably see you know this
is the main thread but i have a
few different ones and my opponent went
quinn d2
um i went bishop g7
and they went to e5 and i feel like e5
you know for the most part is a move
that
makes sense because you're calling out
the bishop
however there was this interesting idea
with knight to f3 and after takes takes
queen d6 now
i have an exchange more
but it's an exchange for one pawn
and also the dark square bishop so
in this positions i guess i'm guessing
the bishop can move back and then you
can use your queen
to put some pressure on this file and
it's not super
sorry diagonal and it's not super simple
on how to play
as black because you know this phone can
start matching the center too
so this would have been nice more than
enough compensation for
for white but they did end up playing
pawn to e5
now i was considering knight takes but i
didn't think it was enough because after
it takes queen
to f2 and after it takes bishop takes
you're not only attacking the queen but
the pawn on f7
so that's not good and
if f6 which was another idea
bishop d5 bishop to e6 was going
queen to b4 takes bishop takes takes
takes
um takes and you know i would say that
it's complicated but not
you know not impossible to play
so yeah f6 was interesting i just went
bishop to f8
now i'm going to regroup my bishop to be
looking at
this diagonal with the help of my queen
and now my opponent made a move that is
kind of bad
they went b4 you can analyze for a
second you know why you think this is a
bad move
because it's not super clear i feel like
um but it is kind of a kind of a bond
move and of course you know i'm guessing
they wanted to avoid bishop to c5
but this is not really the way
to do it
and for example knight to c2
may have been a bit better and after
bishop c5 h3 knight back
king h2 run away from the pin uh give
up your dark square give up my
dark square bishop for the rook and uh
white is going to have more than enough
counterplay because b3
sorry b7 is going to be weak like the
bishop can attack it
uh the pawns can start moving in the
center the diagonal can turn dangerous
so it just kind of feels like
once again they're gonna have more than
enough compensation
but my opponent went b4 and b4 allows me
to play a5
and a5 allows me to hopefully in the
future
uh you'll see the future of this rook
but in the future hopefully it just
helps me you know uh
by being active so
but a3 and after takes takes
group two a2 and now the position i
would say it's
looking extremely good for for black to
the point where you may even argue
for the size of a vintage
and seems like all of the pieces are
kind of pinned
you have to do something because let's
say king which one
i'm gonna give you guys a few minutes um
to try and see what to do as black now
that the key moved and it's no longer in
the pin
so i'm gonna give you a tiny tiny tiny
bit of time to try and solve it
like i said you can always pause the
video here
doesn't matter this speed it's as long
as you solve it
i guess well the speed does matter like
how quickly you solve this puzzle but
um it's not it's not
it's not the most essential thing and if
you want to improve on that
you can always you know focus on the on
the
quality of your answers first and then
time but yeah i've let you guys to think
for
quite a bit and the idea is queen d5
which is very interesting and of course
after it takes rook takes
and uh black has one group more
so that's a main idea to take on d4 and
after
knight f3 protecting rook to d1
putting more pressure keen to h1
takes takes and here i didn't really
want to trade queens
so i went queen to a6
probably i could have taken
on um here
but this looks a bit sketchy
i just play queen a6 and after b5
queen to a4 queen to c1
bishop to f5 it seems like all of my
pieces are kind of active this bishop is
ready to
uh you know get into activity 2.
went to c4 and
i just took so uh according to my notes
it says
i was pissed out my nice position went
down the drain
but he has very very very low time
so i had hope
but yeah so i mean it kind of just
turned from looking really nice for
black to know
it could be you know the game of
anyone is that would they say like
um i don't know but
yeah uh there are
it's double edge you know there are
ideas for both sides
but kling to c4 takes takes
bishop to d3 and the good thing is that
we did get into an end game so there are
not going to be as many threats towards
the white
the white king but it's still very weak
and uh
my pieces are a better place this rook
is nice this knight is scary
the bishop is already threatening to
take some pawns this one is the only one
that kind of needs a place
but um for the most part it just kind of
feels like
the position is rather simple to play as
black
even if um
even if you know if we no longer have
the same potential attack as before
but it does look really nice in my
opinion i don't know
i think that you know black's position
is more than fine
when my opponent played rook c1 i played
bishop to a3
and now let me ask you guys for a brief
moment if you were white pieces i'm
going to flip the board
if you were white pieces how you how
would you proceed here
i'm going to give you a moment so that
you have
enough time to pause solo or do whatever
you want
yeah so if you said rook c3 you're going
to be in some shambles
okay the best move here
would be for example root to d1 and
after bishop takes
b6 big stakes
knight to d2 we should be 6 knight to b4
and still the position looks super good
for
or um
or white but it feels like it's not as
an office in the other line because if
you know if rook to c3 this move is just
losing instantly
because you don't want to stop defending
the opponent's c4
you're just going to lose instantly and
i honestly don't know what is it that my
opponent missed
but they definitely missed something
so black to move here and
how would you guys proceed it's not very
difficult
but just saying
and um if you manage to solve it
congratulations
the right move is rook to a1
and they have some problems with the
background so for example if knight to
g1
then bishop to b2 this is how the game
went
and of course if something like uh
well i don't know what else they could
do
maybe like bishop bach yeah if something
like bishop back now there's not f2
that's a big problem too
so they just played knight to g1
bishop to b2 and i now i'm just winning
and now i'm just straight up winning
because after it takes bishop takes d5
and bishop takes e4 sorry and now knight
to f2
is the threat so you cannot take back
because of this
which is mate and um how are you
supposed to defend this knight
so he played bishop to f1 and after
knight to f2
kg2 knight takes he just resigned so
i mean the thing is that you cannot even
take here right because
there's going to be rook takes you on so
it's just a full rook for nothing
and uh yeah so i think this was a very
interesting game and probably the
crucial moment was
the supposed um body move
probably the crucial moment is supposed
to be the so-called gun movement to g4
i probably had better chances of course
beforehand
um but
i mean i really like this move i don't
know why i think that this is
a this is a move that is
underappreciated by
by a computer and you know it has a very
natural idea so i think um
i think it's not too out of the ordinary
to be honest and of course after rook
takes queen b6 we're gonna put some
pressure on the
on the king and you know as i was
thinking about this game i thought that
i played very like correctly
and when i checked of course it looked
like
the engine was mentioning like the moves
where there were like mistakes and all
of that
but um i mean
if you look at it from the practical
side i would say that this was a very
nice game
i would say that this was a very nice
game and overall
it was very fighting very back and forth
and uh i believe this may have been the
first time that i beat a 2400 over the
board
it may not have been but i don't know in
my memory
it's probably this um
i remember i was like struggling with
like 21 2200 so
this was a nice surprise and i mean i
kind of went on to have a pretty great
tournament
um i think i finished with like five and
a half or something
i don't know i won like 80 rating points
which is a lot
uh i was k40 at the time so
yeah but this was uh this was a nice
game and hopefully now i can find some
other
um i can find like some other you know
example
for another understanding practical
chess that kind of ties to this and
maybe tells the story of the tournament
that came after this one and literally
just
a couple of days after this one because
um
as you guys probably know uh the
what is the name the north american open
always happens like around christmas
time
uh and this tournament was a little
before the sermon was maybe like a week
i had like a week in between more or
less uh between
finishing uh carlos story and then going
to play
in vegas so um
but yeah i can probably find some story
from from my
my tournament in vegas and i mean
overall i think that
you know i think a few things i i think
that
you know if you have a variation
that you can't find any refutation to
but you're not trusting yourself because
your opponent is higher rated
be concrete about it like being concrete
about it is probably the
the main thing if you think that your
line works
go for it items gm's are allowed to make
mistakes too
and um you know don't just doubt
yourself because if you
doubt yourself then you know you're
going to lose time
and probably you're going to change your
mind eventually for a move that is not
as good um
so gaining some confidence you know for
the games
really does help and
i feel like that's one thing that i
experienced with this tournament and the
following one
uh because i played like very free if
that makes sense like i
i kind of played um
like fighting for initiative on
most of the moves and all of that so and
i think you can do too i think
i think you know i i hope that
this kind of uh inspired you a little
bit because i went for some
very practical sacrifice against and i
am and i won so i think
it's uh it's a good example
um i'm not telling you to do like weird
plans of course
in every single game but sometimes you
know if you can fight for the initiative
i think that you should do so
so yeah i think that's gonna be all for
this for this um
lecture i'm probably gonna go film the
other one now
um for today's sunday
uh if you're watching sunday february
7th which i highly
doubt but if you do happy super bowl day
i don't watch football but happy super
bowl
and um yeah i'll probably go film
another
understanding practical chess also sorry
to those of you who wanted to tune into
the twitch stream
my wi-fi was really bad and for some
reason it wasn't working
so i really appreciate this and i'll
probably go film the other video now i
hope you guys enjoyed
this one and um i hope you got some
confidence you know to
play artsy interesting creative
intuitive um
you know attacking lines in your games
against high rated people
just don't be intimidated probably not a
good idea
but yeah so that's gonna be all for this
lecture i hope that you guys
enjoyed my twitch name is taliatally26
so you can go follow me there
and i'll see you all next time bye bye